and this is the part 2 / 3 of our
portfolio extravaganza and there will
also be a continuation of the indesign
piece in the in january i'm looking at
forest we don't I think the dates going
to be released right to do us like a
second follow-up tutorial if anybody
missed the first one and wants to do it
again but I'm really here to say I'm
really thrilled to have Michael Beirut
here of pentagram and just a couple
things in case you don't know who he is
and he was well he's a partner at
pentagram graphic design who works on
most big pieces of architecture you've
seen I'm sure and public pieces of
architecture and public sites in the
city he was prior to that he was ten
years with Vignelli associates Massimo
Vignelli where he was the president of
graphic design and just a couple things
I wanted to mention that might be
interesting to you and one is that he's
done he did the graphics for the New
York Times building which is pretty cool
he also did this public promotion for
the Philip Johnson glass house its kind
of big things small thing and the
redesign of the magazine i love this
like the Atlantic now he is a senior
critic in graphic design at the Yale
School of Art and there's a couple of
books that you might be interested in
he's going to show us some also but one
is the co-editor of the anthology series
looking closer critical writings of
graphic design also a monograph on Tibor
kallmann more common called perverse
optimist and he's the co-author of the
weblog which is a which is a I think
it's a really interesting site actually
and I'm going to make a plug for it so
if you anybody who's interested in kind
of what's going on in design as the web
blog is called design observer and he
also he has commentaries about graphic
design in everyday life and they can be
heard nationally for the
blick radio international program so
he's on public radio so sometimes you're
like going somewhere you tune on public
radio and you might be hearing Michael
David's voice so for all of these
reasons that anymore I welcome Michael
and thank you um you guys can hear me
okay Laurie Thank You Leslie thank you
for inviting me um you guys who this is
I mean drama so well yeah well I'll you
take all the drama I can get you guys
are actually fairly experienced I
understand in some of these graphic
design matters I used I've been giving
these little talks to architects
probably over the last 15 years or so
and when I started I was a you know kind
of this missionary from this distant
land peddling a fairly arcane and not
particularly appealing religion graphic
design it was all about fonts and layout
and things like that and it was it was
like really esoteric as most people you
know to the degree they were interested
they found it difficult to do and most
people would opt to just leave it to the
professionals but that was when I
started doing this that was before the
days of what we called the outset
desktop publishing and those you know
that revolution really took all the
means of production to take a Marxist
phrase and put it in the hands return it
to the hands of the people so um whereas
in 1980s a a long time ago 30 years ago
if you wanted some typesetting done you
had no recourse but to go to a place
that specialize in doing that that it
invest made a huge capital investment in
the machinery that actually set type and
all the fonts that if you bought a font
you were actually buying something that
would be delivered to a loading dock in
wooden crates back in those days you
know so if you want to set you know a
line of helvetica that actually would
take some real doing then when i was in
college of course we had a rubdown
lettering
s type or dry transfer letter electro
set called various things and that was
sort of a type for the uninitiated and
the uninitiated who could afford to do
it by hand with a little stylus and as
long as they had enough letters to go
around they could types at whatever they
wanted one letter at a time um but I'll
come the mid-80s with the introduction
of the personal computer and desktop
publishing suddenly all these things
were more in the hands of not just
license professionals but anyone who had
a computer and nowadays of course you're
constantly being invited every time you
do a microsoft word document or
powerpoint presentation nevermind
InDesign Photoshop Illustrator the
different sorts of programs that you
guys have become familiar with you're
invited to select a typeface and make a
lot of complex graphic design decisions
that um used to be just the purview of
people who were trained specifically to
do just that in trying to think of it so
uh you guys are much more informed than
your predecessors would have been when I
would have been giving a little a dress
like this in an architecture school you
know 15 20 more years ago the the thing
to talk about today is books and I think
you've already talked a little bit about
books the book is object you know how to
organize things and the book set up
we're talking about today are ones that
I've worked on in my studio mostly
having to do with design and
architecture and things like that I
happen to the summer before this one
just passed I moved from a big house to
a much smaller house of combination of
the pressures of the recession and the
departure the eminent departure of the
last kid from our house we no longer
needed the bedrooms and instead needed
some money and decided to move but one
of the unfortunate by products of the
move was that I went from having a
single room that had a million built-in
bookcases to a tiny little room that had
some bookcases that were from
cratenbarrel or pottery barn or
something
right so I had to go on a diet i took
that i ended up taking about I think 40
or so boxes of wood I had 60 boxes of
books I managed to keep 20 of them I
donated 20 of them to a local library up
in Tarrytown New York and I put 20 of
them in storage against the day where I
might have some other house that has
built-in bookcases but in a really
depressing feet of a planning ahead I
did this really horrible depressing
thing where all of the books that I
through with film and theater I put my
son Andrews name on because he's
studying film right now in college all
the books that had to do with history I
put my daughter's name on and all the
and and so my son came in and said why
are my name on these boxes and I said oh
you know there may be some time not
tomorrow not soon hopefully there might
be some time where you and your sisters
are going to have to go out to some
rented warehouse and sort of look at
these books look at these box and say
what's in these boxes oh this one has my
name on it so you can you know one way
or another this is your inheritance so
that also got me thinking not just about
death but also about why why we make why
we buy books why we need to have books
you know and I sort of am culpable in
many ways because I've actually devoted
a good part of my career to designing
these books and some of the books indeed
I was putting in storage heavy
cumbersome bulky hard to lift books in
in big heavy cumbersome hard to lift
boxes I had had a hand and actually you
know causing to come into the world and
I found myself questioning as I was
lifting box number 23 24 25 you know why
the hell I had bothered just creating
all this bulk and um so there must be
some reasons for it so I thought I don't
kind of review you know why we make
books why we buy books why books sort of
matter so you know what are they for
they're obviously you can reach reading
a book on the subway up here a real book
that was on printed on paper but around
me were other people reading books on
devices like Kindles and
and iPads so you know you can have a
book to pass the time paper books still
have a kind of utility I suspect that
will take a while to supplant there's
just something kind of handy about them
you know but they're also used as an aid
to grace and posture and we don't even
know what that book is or whether why I
was selected to kind of teach this lady
how to stand up perfectly straight and
walk in a poised way you know you can
use them to make yourself more of a big
shot you know and then of course you can
i'm just a mask them and then once
you've amassed them of course if it's a
private library as this one is you can
decide that you want to organize them by
the color of their spines you know
that's one way to do it this on the
other hand is a public school library
done it's actually one that i had a hand
in the design of designed by the
architect richard lewis for the robin
hood foundation part of their library
initiative but the most interesting part
of it is the decorations around the
uppermost part of the library that we're
done by the children's book illustrator
in general illustrator myra calm and
Tibor coleman's a wife in fact huge
invited is going to decorate that space
and just kind of created this curated
collection of enigmatic objects that
have some hidden meaning or so she
claims but no one has ever come close to
fathom and what that meaning is as of
yet but it'll be there for a while so we
have time to work on it what books can
do different things really books can be
an archive and now i'm going to say i'm
going to show you a series of books
covers in a couple of spreads that we've
worked on talk a little bit about how we
conceived each of them what we what the
intention was with each of them and
really how they differ one from the next
I think those differences might be
perhaps the most telling part of it for
you guys as you're thinking about how to
tell your own stories as as architects
and how to present you know what could
be complicated arcane work to a barely
interested and perhaps actually
dismissive world as it often is sorry I
didn't mean to be perfect you continue
to be depressing I apologize that yeah
there will be people who are interested
and
I promise they're out there and the
trick is how do you actually take
material and put it in a form that it as
itself as being interesting to the
people who are most likely to be engaged
by so some books sort of function as a
as an archive sometimes the archives
primarily of writing this is a book that
he may have seen it's a compilation of
the critic Paul go burgers writings for
The New Yorker where he writes the
skyline column that appears I think
about once a month or so and heart you
know so when you when you design a book
a commercial book at least you have
several clients your direct client is
not in this case call though Berger who
I think had a was shown things but
didn't have the we we got very little
direct instruction from him instead we
were really working for the publisher
when this case is monticelli press which
is an imprint of Random House so their
interest is how does how do you kind of
like give this book won a title and then
to a cover design and three and interior
layout that will appeal to someone in a
book called hmm appeal to someone appeal
first to a buyer for say barnes and
nobles barnes and noble or borders or a
big bookstore chain perhaps look good in
a small thumbnail on an amazon page and
signal the people what kind of book it
is so are going to books of our initial
criticism are seldom show up on any
bestseller list except the you know the
one at that they had urban center books
i guess but um go burgers writing as you
know is engaging it's for a general
audience and i think the trick here was
to take a lot of repurposed articles and
kind of cast them in a way that would
make the most of their current relevance
and so on we could have had a much more
bookish treatment of the title but
instead we opted for one that was a set
and very bold sans-serif typographies
the type is called bow like the first
three letters in Bauhaus the the
inverted skyscrapers in the top
skyline of Chicago was selected a lot of
debate about about whether there should
be any buildings on the front of this
the feeling from the publisher is that
putting buildings on the front would
clue people into the fact that this book
was about architecture but then there
was a lot of kind of soul searching
about what buildings one would show
because it seemed to preclude or be too
specific and preclude the kind of broad
range of material that a goal burger was
writing about so the question was what
to put on the front inverting that image
seemed to kind of render it abstract
enough and played a little bit into the
up and down in the title and then the
the pages on the inside I think belies
slightly their magazine roots by having
very pronounced headlines more
pronounced me would be in a more
academic book I would say or more
conventional book and illustrations the
ones that appeared I believe in the
original print edition of The New Yorker
and then we had a little conceit where
we simply took the the beginning of each
essay and set it in a bigger type size
and that happened to do with the
discovery made that Goldberg or tended
to write as magazine journalists do I
think tenants right kind of grabby
beginnings because they're competing for
people's attention in The New Yorker
that's with short stories other kinds of
reporting cartoons ads for what various
luxury goods so go burger had that sort
of like start these things with a little
bit of a bang and and so we made the
most of advice making all those
introductions a little bit bigger oddly
enough i said this belied its magazine
roots but in fact the you know if you
guys know the new yorker the new yorker
in fact it's very very understated and
slay out very unchanging in the way it's
presented its typography and its stories
and this and in a way is much more
aggressive than the new york or whatever
dare with the Santa you know heavy
sans-serif headline and of that big
thing that you call a deck I believe in
journalistic terms and so would say it's
a different sort of treatment than it
had in this original life and indeed I
found in reading the book both then as
we were reading it in galleys after its
set these essays actually read
friendly to me than they did in the
original New Yorker pieces where they
seemed much more disposable and much
more kind of a you could you come at
them much more cursory sort of way I
think putting something in a book makes
a bigger claim on your attention
likewise you know that that uh that
convention that we just sort of said on
the picture would come down from the top
it the picture would define so whether
if it's at all picture like this one or
short picture like that when it was sort
of defined in the end how much room
would be allowed at underneath for that
little introductory bit here that's only
four lines here and it's more lines
there right just one kind of archive
book this is another one ah this was a
Robert stern repurposing some older
essays from 1964 to 1988 and say no this
is published by a Yale press and it's
much more I'd say formal in the way that
it's set up so very simple layouts
doesn't have the doesn't use the devices
of a magazine layout as the goldberger
book does this is about as conventional
a book as I think you'll see here but I
think part of the thing was just sort of
make this thing feel like a you know a
repository of some clouds and slightly
dated but kind of injury I think all the
more interesting because because of
their auntie equality in some cases if
you can call 1978 sufficient provenance
for an antique they said oh they're more
interesting might be more interesting to
reach a day than they were even at the
time through the lens of the successive
years again of most able to work on have
pictures in them and figuring out the
balance between pictures and text is a
real challenge you guys will be told or
perhaps even believe that quote unquote
people don't read anymore and yet people
do read if you give them something
interesting the trick is how much
confidence you have in the material that
you're putting in front of them how much
writing is enough writing how much
writing is too much writing I find a lot
of times particularly when I'm working
more pure architectural monographs and
particularly the more straightforward
ones that there's a sort of like
grinding quality to the descriptions of
the work that's shown you know where you
just kind of tell you know ok I only
have you know I only have 11 more to go
after i write this one not only have 10
more to go is it someone doing like you
know horrible kind of weight resistance
calisthenics to know n gettin sweaty is
they're going to plowing through these
project descriptions you know for this
project where the site was slow p and
the person wanted a you know place to
put their horse you know I'm just kind
of I don't know then just goes on and I
don't know so it's sort of tough this is
a different though because with these
all these pictures are just marginalia
that are illustrating points that are
raised in the main essays right this is
a brand new book that we've done for
with Tony viddler is the author it's a
joint publication between Yale and the
Canadian Centre for architecture and
it's about literally an archive it's
about Jim James Sterling's archive which
is held up a anam at the canadian centre
and again with it this is this is a
really i would say fairly esoteric book
but an important one because it's really
exposing a whole wealth of material from
the archive of an architect that is much
less known than a lot of other ones who
are much less known a morir more
influential i would say than a lot of
other ones of his generation a lot of
other ones with whom he will show space
on bookcases and in bookstores this is
literally an archive it's a bunch of
boxes that he had amassed over the
course of his career sterling was a like
a lot of architects a real and veteran
saver of early sketches presentations
working drawings presentation drawings
and all of these are basically in the
archive and kind of gone through very
carefully by Tony and his staff the
cover actually shows a you know a model
in a box fragile keep lid on it says
just a kind of like you that is that and
I think what we tried to do is interrupt
these fairly quiet
pieces there's a lot of very light
sketches a lot of pieces that are really
ephemeral with with a series of kind of
very bold divider pages that clearly to
the reader are meant to guide you
step-by-step through the various parts
of this book the writing is very
multivalent there's a combination of
aphorisms quotes interpretive material
long captions for the pieces and so
again one of the things that one has to
do when you're working with a text that
has a lot of different sort of internal
voices in it has come up with different
ways of presenting each of those voices
so the reader who kind of know who's
talking at any one time and like I said
it's hbu unlike a lot of the books we do
these days this one was printed really
beautifully in Italy you can really see
every single detail on these drawings I
really recommend it to you not so much
for the design which i think is fairly
understated but very serviceable but for
the material itself which I think it's
pretty remarkable and there's a whole
series of great drawings done on the
back of like airplane boarding passes
and things as students of architecture
it's a it's really nearly pornographic
and its interests I daresay so another
thing a book can be is a record this is
straightforward record of things this is
a book that a stern did based on a
series of tapes he had conducted he had
recorded in interviews with Philip
Johnson obviously before he stuff and I
this is one of my favorite books have
ever worked on because this is the the
basic raw material consists of two
things there's the transcripts of these
tapes which are very chatty and Johnson
was a real rack on tour as you probably
heard you know had some sort of co2 cell
connected with this material that it
couldn't be published until a certain
period of time had passed after his
death he's basically it's it's um I
don't want to take scatty outright but
it's like a lot of judgments being
passed on all sorts of different people
so the transcript itself was very
entertaining to read however
or maybe um one of the reasons
everything to read is that really feels
like like a gossipy in talk between
Johnson who like knew everything and a
younger robert am stern who at that
point didn't quite know everything but
was trying to keep up with Johnson as he
kind of followed along in these tapes
Johnson keeps dropping names of things
quick references to things and so one of
the entertaining things that was that
Stern organized was a the book itself
has a running text and then the we sort
of used for footnoted all the references
in the text sometimes with photographs
sometimes just with footnotes and they
kind of ran along so Johnson we just
throw in someone's last name really
quickly and there's a footnote
explaining who that person was and
sometimes showing a photograph of that
person you know in the you know so
that's a he mentions a huge Stubbins
along there on the left-hand page little
picture a few Stubbins just identifying
at a time there is a on the right there
is Johnson's official transcript from
Harvard it seems to have done okay not
great he's like an indifferent student I
believe at Harvard but it's sort of
lately so this book is actually really
I'm really proud of it partly because it
sort of has this you know there's the
transcript which is just very colloquial
and then the footnotes which usually are
kind of just you know mind-numbingly
academic here kind of our this
counterpoint or kind of almost like a
you know like like what would be online
a pop-up thing of the kind of identify
each of these obscure references by the
way if as I'm talking anyways a question
just raise your hand we can ask for me
to go along and I'll do questions at the
end of course as well um this book is a
record two very different project i
mentioned that library initiative that
new york's robin hood foundation had
started about 10 years ago now and a a
few years ago they decided they wanted
sort of document the whole thing and not
just as a coffee table book and indeed
this is a small paperback book that I
don't think
is coffee table worthy instead this is
meant to be a handbook that people could
use to go out and kind of like improve
their local library as well so um we had
done this logo for the project that
embedded that ! inside the word library
by substituting for the letter i and the
book itself is a combination of things
that it it kind of goes down and more or
less picks out every one of the
libraries that were done there about 30
to 50 libraries that were either done or
in process while this book was being
done sort of goes through and does like
a little taxonomy of the library
explains what the relevant parts were
with the strategy was to bring to life
this one was done i think at by henry
Myerberg when he was working with david
rockwell and it's basically just a
gymnasium i think that was repurposed to
be a library but then there's also a lot
of work about the process that went into
making these things this is a library in
by the Brooklyn Navy yard's I think
where I'm the graphic artist Peter
Arkell did the series of black-and-white
illustrations and you can see the
resolution is not fabulous in the screen
but he can sort of see in the upper
upper right there a drawing that he did
from a photographic reference showed
immediately to the left and then there
was this questionnaire that he used to
record kids reactions to book so all
this was kind of documented
journalistically in the drawings you see
on the wall in the illustration on the
lower right and there's a there's a
library by myra coleman again so
sometimes there's a nice close-up look
at one of the libraries as well so this
book is really meant to be something
this is Princeton Architectural press to
this one we pick century schoolbook as
the typeface a lot of times I sort of
will pick typefaces just because they
have some pleasing to me relationship to
the subject matter and sometimes that
works out pretty well sometimes it
doesn't work and I have to change it but
in this case sort of the quintessential
kind of children's storybook typeface
to work pretty well as the type base for
this you can see clearly where it says
PS 106 up there sometimes books are an
occasion to reassess someone's career or
body of work again this is a joint
publication from the yale university
press and the Yale School of
Architecture and it's basically the
started as a symposium on Johnson and
it's mostly just major essays about
Johnson and his work combined with
images that were probably shown most
likely shown during the actual lectures
that were delivered at the symposium so
this is a very kind of straightforward a
book for reading oversized kind of
deliberately kind of elegant and uh
divided up in a kind of different
sections and I forget why was that we
kind of hit on that that that
affectation of the period after
everything I know maybe he's meant to
sort of like the give this whole thing a
little bit of a memorial quality you
know full stop or something I don't know
and a lot of work was done to find that
a image which is Johnson at the dining
table in the glass house with the this
kind of strange reflects is it a
reflection you know what's being
reflected are we looking in or out sort
of thing which I think was meant to
reinforce the nature of the both of the
original symposium and of the material
that was a mass for this book and again
this is a case where it's you know
deliberately choosing she's choosing
kind of early deliberately what kinds of
images best represent a project these
were all from Johnson's work at Lincoln
Center from sketches to the interior of
a bomb thing i'm a job of the new york
state theater right yeah oh this is not
yet published but it's another
reassessment this is this book that
Yale's doing on Kevin Roche which I have
them it was most in one of the most
interesting and surprising books I've
done recently
yeah it's Roach I thing as an architect
that not that I may be wrong speaking
here but it's he's not thought of well I
don't know anything he's like he's not
regarded period you know either good or
bad or even known that much now but has
a really interesting and kind of
relevant it'll be increasingly relevant
body of work I think going forward and
so it's a this is a case where though
the work is if you know his work it kind
of reached its zenith in this sort of
corporate experience this kind of
corporate corporate corpl incorporate
perhaps corporate opulence sort of and
so we needed need choices about the
typography that can stand up to these
really strong images that are kind of
very geometric sometimes even rather
shiny like this one is and kind of could
really work and kind of feel like it's
big and brawny and sort of a corporate
that's used if you get a chance when
this book's not yet published so you're
just looking at layouts here but it's
got a couple of fantastic things in it
that I got to go through first-hand one
of them one of them that I learned was
that roaches a master presenter he just
can really present architectural ideas
with the kind of clarity that I don't
have ever sent any architect do quite so
well he you know he started in working
as one of Eros Aaron ends right hand
guys and I suspect in that capacity he
had to be easy their interpreter a lot
and kind of explain rationales for
sometimes even indent rationales for
ideas that sarin and would have about
why I building should look this way
versus that way so it's hard to tell
here but the thing on the left is a
series of slides that he used to present
the original proposal to the somewhat
suspicious board of the felt of Ford
Foundation and this became the ford
foundation building that you guys
probably know over on West 42nd Street
run was twenty four forty third Street
42nd right it was the big bit of big
Corten steel interior atrium this is to
a crowd of people who were expecting a
dignified building that had views of
looked out into fresh air not into an
interior atrium and not made out of what
they ended up making out of either and
he somehow managed to sell them on this
idea and it's quite remarkable when you
sort of see how he built the logic tree
that led to it and a lot of amazing
patterns a thing you see up there on the
upper left is the carpet pattern for the
Cummins engine a technical center in
Columbus Indiana and you see a little
bit of that carpet pattern kind of
getting played out below kind of amazing
mind at work Angela and so this is
actually a structured very much with Si
so the interpretive assessment SAS at
the beginning that they go into a conic
catalogue resume in the end part where
each project is shown and described in a
fairly straightforward way so there is
kind of a a record to accompany the
reassessment sometimes things are
outright tributes I apologize for all
this new haven stuff down here in
Morningside Heights it's what I got you
know it's it's the songs that I know so
I'll sing them but um you know they got
this building they got up there designed
by Paul Rudolph they just got a fairly
elaborate restoration and the on the
occasionally getting reopened a really
interesting little book of Rudolph's
writings were published and kind of
given out there and so available that
are again Yale press and architecture
co-published and with then I think this
gets down to sort of almost an absolute
zero level of decisions for someone as a
graphic designer like me to be making
because i think it's basically just
writing and you just want to do a few
little things to kind of relate the
object of the book which is a very very
modest little paperback probably about
six by eight let's say and only you know
probably a hundred and you know sixty or
so pages relatively thin modest little
book you know how do you build and just
to make a couple of choices is just
related in some gentle way to the to the
occasion and because this was the
occasion was the rededication of the art
and architecture building that he did up
there
on the Yale campus which I'm sure I
assume you can all picture in your mind
the kind of an example of cast concrete
cantilevered robust American Yankee
Brutalism with a nice strong sans-serif
typeface and inside we kind of did this
maneuver that is sort of a cheap trick
for a graphic designer but you see how
it kind of goes in and out in those
shapes that's obviously or at least
hobby or ibly obvious to me a reference
to kind of the formal language
specifically that building and certainly
one that Rudolf used elsewhere as well
and sometimes it just kind of is simply
functional as shown here it's just kind
of accommodating slightly wider
photographs but we did things one
wouldn't necessarily have to do like
stead like the photographs go in the
text is like a volume in the photographs
go in one level the captions don't call
him quite so far so it's kind of treated
in this sort of a plastic sort of way
that I think well I wouldn't presume to
say how much relation but have the way
Rudolfo conceived the spaces in that
building but it's meant to be a little
bit of a tribute to it as I said in that
title piece and a lot of these books if
you go to read solely or places like
that are obviously trophies of one typer
and other entro fees for whom is the
question this is a book Monacelli did
for daniel libeskind like I said you
know obviously in the previous book we
had no contact whatsoever with Paul
Rudolph who has been a you know dead for
some time Daniel and Nina leave his skin
were very involved with this book and
there's a lot of going back and forth
about how it would be presented and a
lot of a lot of going back and forth
again about the cover which is actually
of it's the presentations fairly you
know it's just a wrapped hardcover book
but it's got a silver cover and I'm very
proud of the fact that what we did is we
took this drawing one of those drawings
that he did earlier on in his career and
did this little maneuver that Ian sort
of make out there where it's called
counterpoint and it's past the lines
kind of sometimes go on top of the
letters and sometimes underneath the
letters it's sort of
it was tricky and very hard to do when I
hope has a subtle sort of effect on the
ambiguity of the ambiguous reading of
the cover material and the material
which is basically they're not scholarly
essays they're just recorded commentary
by liebe scanned on the projects as you
go through them we made a deliberate
choice and this was the designers
volunteered this as an idea of taking a
statement about each project and blowing
up really big and using that in effect
as the title page for a section so this
obviously introduces the Jewish Museum
in Berlin and the typeface which is a
very mechanical type base that I think
you guys might recognize because it's
not it's not a graphic design Adobe
typeface it's a cab typeface kind of
works in concert with more normal
typefaces like helvetica and I think
garum on that sort of carry the more a
textual work of it so there's some as we
did with the rudolph one there are like
the the text and the photographs
interact a little bit you can see in the
lower right-hand corner there that
narrow column of text kind of like nips
in and kind of violates the corner there
and this is happening and a little bit
more of a kind of meaning in any sort of
way more of the way leave the skin
designs rather than the kind of big kind
of robust kind of punchy gestures that
Rudolf our favorite or so it appears to
me you guys made just really judge for
yourself but do you see I mean I think
that little the little thing is
happening right here that's like a more
leave a skinny sort of a little thing a
little artifact of where the caption is
sort of hitting the picture then you get
that funny little residual shape you
know and then sometimes just like these
trophy books require moments cinemas
Senate cinematic moments of just big
glamorous a full bleed photography that
goes left to right top to bottom same
publisher a very different book
landscape architect Ken Smith you guys
probably know
nice work as well and he has this very
kind of to my mind sort of funny and
deadpan way of working that just as very
you know disarmingly straightforward and
so the book itself is like disarmingly
straightforward we have this very weird
I think weird looking to me hand drawn
well all typefaces are hand-drawn sort
of but uh it's the kind of a redrawn
sans-serif typeface that was a friend of
the designer on this product the
designer workman his project had done it
as a student project and just thought it
had this sort of a charming awkwardness
that kind of suited a lot of the work
that's the upper and lowercase version
of it and you can barely make out the
type is all in color and the color kind
of has this gradual shift from Webster
right from blue into green so it's meant
to sort of everything's meant to just be
I think more engaging more vivacious not
feel like this is a formal book about
landscape architecture Allah homestead
or you know you know traditional 19th
century landscape artists or more study
there 20 since we left there but can
these kind of you know he'll use plastic
flowers and hula hoops if that seems to
be warranted kind of landscape
architecture the man himself there on
the left and then we also wanted to have
you know the photo page is just be
really blunt and straightforward picture
on the left picture on the right so then
there are these kind of books he's kind
of like just like just stately march
through portfolios this is where I think
the writing sort of gets kind of tough
and these in a way resembles sort of the
channel you know you guys put in your
portfolio you have these projects how do
you describe them how do you present
them how do you order them how do you
group them right and so this is sort of
about as straightforward as you can get
it says the name of the project in the
upper left describes when it was done
and what kind of thing it is in the
adjacent to it beneath it is one of
those descriptions you know and then
there's a series of pictures that
describes what goes on inside right
we've done a bunch of these for
for mr. stern and it's interesting
because the the ones which one of these
you think sells the most which one
houses right you know why cause people
to buy then get ideas for things to do
in there for yeas right unless you're
actually charged with decorating a
college campus the top one is going to
be much you know practical use to you
although I think if you get a chance the
one on top actually is a little bit
different from the other the three below
because it it's so it's it's obviously
the premise of it is it's a book of it's
a book of cataloguing the firm's work on
college campuses but each of the
sections begins with what I think is a
really lovely intelligent contextual sa
this sort of describes what makes you
know any1 college campus the specific
college games he's talking about
different what their traditions are what
their challenges are and so forth with a
great just enough kind of historical
supplementation that really makes it
worth reading I think I'm you know all
of the books we've done a for stern and
with them have been really interesting
intellectual challenges these are kind
of the magnum OPI think that end up
always kind of really testing our mettle
as designers but I think each one of
them has some rewards to be found even
if you're not necessarily interested in
the picture book quality i think the
writing is always kind of sensitive and
well researched particularly the top one
which is a i think the newest of all
those in sometimes books are but
sometimes books themselves can kind of
be biography and you guys know this book
it's really really interesting this is
one where i'm yael and where that our
banter had done had done this as a
project actually where they asked a
whole bunch of architects to sort of do
two things one catalog their own
bookcases and then select ten books that
you name as your favorites and what's
interesting in this you know I don't
know if you're like me but if you like
books and you're at someone's in
someone's house or in their apartment
and their bookcases there I find myself
always sort of you know eventually
wandering you know if it's a party or
something and I'm not being watched
carefully I'll wander off and I'll just
sort of like start seeing what books
around there Oh case and it's sort of
interesting you know that that
collection in some way kind of it
becomes a little biography of who their
owner is and sometimes I wonder where
the people actually buy books or display
them think just was thinking that um you
know it'll speak well I mean obviously
this is something where some people have
done this so having these books will
speak well of them I know a a woman who
sells who runs a rare bookstore here in
Manhattan and when I ask or how business
is sometimes I mean her business rises
and falls sometimes depending on whether
nouveau riche people are building
McMansions that include libraries that
require books on their shelves to make
them look convincing and not any books
will do they have to be proper books and
people literally you know interior
designers of decorators will go to her
and say well he's interested in you know
armies and boats and football and you
know and then she'll write that down and
then come and and and we're looking to
spend about X amount in them you know um
I assume later on you know a truck shows
up in the big winding driveway and has a
bunch of boxes like the boxes I was
bagging excited then mr. got rocks then
can walk in with pride to his library
and kind of you know sit and kind of you
know read Sports Illustrated or do su
doku or whatever it is one does in a
library these days and surrounded
knowing that all these books reflect his
interests or at least his interests that
it was characterized by his interior
design consultant to a bookseller he
never met and so on books can be
biography this is actually a little bit
more down to earth and real than that
scenario i just subscribed and so
there's a the sort of shows sort of the
this actually very straight for
kind of pornographic again if you if you
want to or voyeuristic at least not
pornographic it'll go into a number of
different architects including say Peter
Eisenman photograph of his library shown
there on the right and then a little
interview with him about you know why
books are important or what he's
interested in a white bought the books
he bought and then it's actually this
very kind of like you can actually read
the titles step-by-step shots of of the
bookcases run do and see what he's got
there then there's always a part at the
end where for each of these library
owners they pick their top ten books and
this is actually this is a challenge
really to you know very crucial
statement one senses you know how how
predictable should one be what are some
books one must simply name or you know
leaving them off would be just shocking
what ringers can you throw in to show
that you're not like all the other
people in the book so you can see that
um if you read it's got um huysmans got
um walter benjamin and then Corbusier
Jacques Derrida of course I suppose
light and August by William Faulkner
that's a little surprising I think Kenny
guys recognize the one of the far right
just from the cover alone I forget what
that is on the top then oh then you got
a cool house and pension and complexity
contradiction i believe complexity and
contradiction was the winner in terms of
most name by most people i think for
some reason well for obvious reasons
brush so this is this cute little book
too and while we were working they kept
saying oh this is going to be really a
popular book and it just sort of seemed
like this exercise of the thing but it
did turn out to sell really really well
and was really fun to work on and also
really fun to look at it sort of fun and
sort of you feel a little bit cheap
looking at it cuz it's sort of it's not
like reading any of these books but you
sort of feel like you're having a highly
literary experiences in the hands of all
these avatars right and finally on books
can be legacies as well this is a book
we did on eros errands let me see this
book actually and the Kevin Roche book
are direct
companions with each other finding that
photograph on the top on the front cover
which shows the final placement or the
first attempted final placement of the
Keystone on the st. Louis memorial arch
you can sort of see underneath you can't
quite make it obvious like a huge crowd
of people gathered underneath for this
momentous occasion and if I recall
because of the the expansion that would
happen in the joints in the metal they
were trying to do it's like first thing
in the morning and have been cool
overnight and somehow it just didn't
work they had a wait till got all the
warmer something so it fit I don't know
there's something like that or maybe
vice versa at any rate they try to
January times just in a bit get away a
little bit to make it work and so this
is a case where it's a bunch of critical
assessments of a look at some major
projects and then a going carefully one
at a time through a bunch of smaller
more modest projects as well again in
this case one of our challenges was with
all these it's like picking a typeface
and kind of picking a format materials
is always an interesting thing we picked
this typeface called ultimately
sometimes called euro style sometimes
called micro gamma designed in 1952 i
believe and very sort of i thought the
apropos for the height of sarin ends
powers also has those you know iya the
words ero actually look great in it
because it has a kind of Roundy sort of
like thing happening with it and not
unlike some of the forms that he ended
up using in some of the buildings as
well then this is a very recent book
also an archive I'm know if the only you
guys have seen this this was a book that
we had a big hand and putting together
we were approached by Jane Thompson we
just won the cooper-hewitt a Lifetime
Achievement Award the married to the
architect Ben Thompson who is with the
architects collaborative up in Boston
and was the mind behind the renovation
of faneuil hall in Boston and then
replace in Baltimore and then South
Street Seaport here in New York and his
progeny probably unhappily includes all
sorts of festival marketplaces all over
the place but on way back when in the
60s and 70s he and Jane ran this store
in downtown Cambridge called design
research which is arguably the store
that kind of introduced the idea of
design as retailing or retailing as
design to America and introduced it was
first store where a lot of design
products were available anywhere in
North America and it really was because
the Thompson just had an eye for an
enthusiasm for this sort of thing the
store was open probably for less than 10
years had enormous influence and then
closed Ben Thompson died Jane Thompson
is well along in years and I think was
really interesting kind of creating an
archive of the influence of the store
now gone so that people could actually
see it so the store is really
interesting and it sort of consists of a
the book consists of some essays by Jane
and others but the bulk of it is a
series of interviews conducted by the
writer Alexandra lang who just went
around and talked to dozens of people
constructing sort of an oral history of
the store people who work there are
people who knew of it people who shop
there and then cobble these things
together into sort of a running
narrative sort of Allah the book ed by
George Plimpton about Edie Sedgwick
where he had done old you know I don't
know if you know that book but Clinton
was writing his book about you know
Warhol and 60s superstar Edie Sedgwick
and in order to assemble that he went
undid all these interviews and then
decided with his co-author Jean Stein
instead of taking the interviews and
turning them into a book by putting
quote marks around things and he said
she said he just kind of would say you
know this person said that and then that
was the quote just kind of like lined up
all the all the direct quotes one after
another so basically this book works
that way so those voices you barely see
there like that but there's also a kind
of like a roster of the products that
were shown in the store
some of which as I said for the first
time and then finally this is s
utilizing a book can be sort of an
argument an argument favor of something
and I think the classic one of those was
this one that you all know which was
still being argued you know as recently
as a year or so though because imposing
the head up at Yale sort of not so much
about the Venturi's but about actually
the influence of that particular book on
the profession and we were asked to
design the catalogue for the current
show that's at the cooper you
cooper-hewitt national design museum
called why design now which is there a
design tree any ille so we were doing
the catalogue of it and was conceived as
an argument this is my notes from the
original meeting we have with the
curators where they're really talking
about a survey of work done in
categories we're all meant to be you
know statements of issues facing the
world at large energy mobility health
prosperity community etc etc and our
challenge was how do you turn this into
a book so with your permission if you
want i'm just going to take you really
slow that knew something you really
slowly I'll take it really quickly
through the process of what it would
what actually goes into doing a book
today so the books called why design now
that's the name of the exhibition from
the forward it says we ask questions
throughout the exhibition and within
this cattle engage the viewer and the
reader you know why and how is design
thinking an essential tool for solving
some of today's most urgent problems why
should business leaders policymakers
consumers and citizens embrace design
values I want as I'm promote
environmental stewardship social equity
accessibility and creative capital so
this book is meant to actually serve as
a bit of a provocation about these
issues through the medium of a bunch of
examples of pieces that are answering
these questions in different ways so the
National Design training all and it's
360 for selected projects answer these
questions / with an attention to
provoking further discussion and so it
was supposed to be enduring provocative
useful responsible and entertaining as a
book that last thing is easy to forget
but um everything you do is competing
with someone for someone's attention
with against other things against
their desire to play xbox or desire
their need to change their kid's diaper
their need to go pee their desire to go
to the movies you know and you're kind
of saying well I have something might be
worth your time and even if you're sure
it is you somehow have to make it easy
for them to sort of come to agree with
you and devote a little bit of their
time to finding out what it is you're
trying to tell them and so all of those
things begin with an essay consisting of
fifty nine thousand eight hundred or
three hundred eighty nine words shown
here a bunch of series of essays
actually 370 images one in the book so
these are the raw materials we start
with you guys start with you know a site
and a program and a budget presumably we
start with a budget and a bunch of words
and much of pictures and there are three
hundred eighty four projects organizing
those eight sections by theme the more
or less state exactly as they were
stated in the original meeting we had
with the curatorial team they already
had commissioned someone not us to
design a graphic identity for the
exhibition using a specific type face
and so I'm very I'm not a real not
invented here sort of person I like it
when someone prompts me with something
and says by the way you have to use this
sometimes is some hideous thing and you
have to work your way around it this i
thought was perfectly serviceable and so
we stuck with that at the starting point
also because of all these vaunted claims
that the curators were making about
social responsibility environmentalism
sustainability etc it seemed you know if
we're bothering kind of like making a
book and you know and renews into the
world it had to be done on the most
environmentally sensible sensitive way
possible hence you know forest ffs see
Forest Service from those a certified
paper that they have to do with the
forestry was sustainable that rendered
the paper soy-based sink which is
biodegradable biodegradable shrink
wrapper to came in carbon credits that
were traders method reduction carbon
neutral and then a concise purposeful
design
but we didn't want to be coffee table
book we wanted to be a reference book of
guy to handbook and a manual but still
entertaining you know so the typeface is
the type case we inherited was this
thing called Griffith gothic which is a
very functional typeface it has
functional roots was done by this guy
named CW Griffith in the 30s for Bell
Telephone it's the typeface of every
telephone book you've ever seen was set
in or a offspring of that type a so then
you have actually seen a telephone book
which may not be true that telephone
book was what the person was sit the kid
was sitting on playing the piano you've
never seen one before before the
internet you'd look up phone numbers in
these books paper books beneath it is a
brand new type based called Chronicle by
Tobias frere-jones and Jonathan Hepler
that's a very much a reading typeface so
we combine those two then we decided in
order to add some entertainment value
introducing color to these things and
the colors we like work these colors of
these really bright highlighting markers
for reasons you'll see in a second what
we did was to sort of parse this thing a
little more clearly take each of those
eight sections and assign each of them
one of those bright magic marker colors
right so the aid section thing which was
sort of the organizing rationale behind
the whole book became something we
really wanted to spotlight and so then
we thought what we could do then is have
a book that kind of had a fairly boring
straightforward cover but if we kind of
use those eight colors kind of an
amusing way we get this tasty sort of
Necco wafer kind of effect and we looked
at the book sideways and that's shown
there on the left so the basic idea of
the book was we actually use those
highlighting colors to highlight things
just like this and so this is a mock-up
we did early on showing what we intended
to do we intended to kind of like them
pick out the key thoughts from the book
highlight them in the color to that
those thoughts were associated with
whether they were one of those eight
sections and then when we came to the
parts where the themes were illustrated
with work from the exhibition those
pages were flooded in the colors that
were associated with their respective
sections as well and so this actually
solved number of problem
when you're doing this sort of thing you
guys won't have this problem in
assembling your own portfolios but in
this case 134 different projects none of
which respect especially photographed by
us for the book it was always sort of
like please send us a picture of that
project then something would come in it
could be on a white background a black
background in scituate a drawing a model
you know a good photograph and also go
to photograph and these and when you're
faced with that situation you need to
kind of lay down a really nice solid
these things are on the highway they put
a nice net underneath them some none of
them actually fall off and kill
themselves and so this these color
things became sort of the strong net
that kind of held up all these 134
different ways of interpreting things
right and so in doing the book we
created a bunch of sample pages that we
used to test out the idea and to obtain
kind of a go-ahead from the curatorial
team and the publication staff at the
cooper-hewitt these were shown here the
layout of any of these things is done
almost as you would storyboard a movie
or anything else this is most of the
book channel from top to bottom and I
think in this form you get to very
clearly see the relationship between
those color thematic versions and how
they progress through page after page of
the book once we committed to that we
got caught up in this fairly harrowing
process of testing those colors because
the cooper-hewitt couldn't afford and
then we wouldn't ask them to afford the
luxury of printing each of those colors
as a custom color going through the
press just by itself to receive ink that
have been specially mixed to be that
color most for color things you see as
you probably know we're actually
compiled from four basic inks black
magenta yellow and cyan and so so it was
with these colors too we had these magic
marker colors that we like them we had
to figure out CMYK values that would
simulate them closely and even once we
did that seeing what would happen when
they hit different kinds of paper was
always a challenge right and then
there's a you know shown here working
out my new calculations that it took to
mash those precisely they're getting
color proofs as well of the images that
would appear again
a little bit challenging because of the
various source various sources that the
of the images we worked really hard on
the cover and we went back and forth
with the printer quite a bit you can
sort of see that thing on the left there
that we ended up calling the BP version
because it sort of looks like a massive
virulent toxic oil spill kind of like
resting on top of the book actually kind
of a cool anti design approach I suppose
but it was so repellent as a physical
object that we just couldn't bear to
propagate it i guess and the thing you
see on the right is closer to what we
ended up doing it's just a piece of
blackboard with y design not punched
into it and so the book itself like she
looks like this again sort of
entertainment value in trying to make it
engaging by showing images nice and big
on occasion it's a thing in them in that
drug town down Midian right they'd said
auger day that doing all those fantastic
projects in Medina and then of the the
idea of the highlighting introduced
early on and the table of contents and
you can sort of see it anticipates what
you'll encounter later on as those
colors peek out at you from the side and
then it just plays this way through all
the way like that so you'll recognize
some of these illustrations I'm sure
obviously a projected Harrison these
colors go a little bit haywire but we
worked back and forth to make sure that
they were all kind of balanced and
didn't impede the reading of the text
too much and then of the back there's
simply of because the book was sold in
that biodegradable shrink-wrapped and
publishers were always concerned that
people would have wouldnt be able to
fathom what was in this book without
with because it has no pictures we sort
of just printed with the hopes that
people would read it on the back this
little presea of the books content so
that's it that's everything I've got to
show you about books I didn't use
anywhere near the two hours i was told i
had to go on dell exists little time for
questions if any of you have any so i'd
be happy to take them if you've got them
it's a horrible day outside you want to
say gonna ask a lot of questions yes
please that's correct
um um architects are only I mean we all
have clients and they all they come in
different varieties I actually I like
architects all and I like talking with
architects a lot so I and also I phim it
I'm very I'm when it comes to these
books I have us I go in with a
projecting well I go I was gonna say go
with a great deal of humility but I
actually probably go in effecting a
great deal of humility rather than
actually um being humble I'm sorry about
as humble as any other designer as I
suppose but I think a lot of it is that
once you having I don't have any ideas
of my own for these books basically you
know I don't like you know I don't go in
I just not none of these books looked at
way because I always wanted to do a book
that looked like that they really do
truly come out of the content in some
cases you know when it's a monograph the
content really is the the personality
the architect in some cases those
personalities very out of scale I
learned early on to my eye because I've
worked when I worked for Massimo
Vignelli he hit the offices were 475
tenth Avenue same building as Richard
Meier and guac me Segal and I sort of
remember being on you know as a young
designer beyond elevator with Richard
Myra thinking you know he's like the
same he's like a music an adult man just
like my dad in Ohio except he doesn't
really seem you know I don't think they
can't even picture them together they
seem to be different species of people
and and part of that reason is i think
you know when i started like seeing
architects in action collaborating with
them doing signage projects let's say I
just kind of learned that the successful
ones among all the other things they
have to master somehow it will stand in
a room and convince a lot of confused
fearful strong-minded and maybe not so
smart people to invest the stupendous
amount of money on some project just
simply based on some little model on a
table or some renderings on boards you
know and that does take a lot of
personality so when I in them and then
even the ones that aren't famous
sometimes are studying to be famous and
so they act like that too and then
sometimes the other ones act like that
just because they read the fountainhead
and so they end up all kind of being
handfuls to deal with in one way or
another but usually when I go when I
listen carefully and generally
Architects make have made for me fairly
good clients there are critiques of
stuff that I've done sometimes they get
very you know the danger is that they'll
get very prescriptive you know this will
work if you do exactly that and you know
what you don't want is them reaching for
the medicine cabinet you just want them
to tell you what hurts you know and then
you will figure out what pill is the
best remedy for that right so but thats
it's true with architects is true with
any anything else I mean I kind of
learned my place early on and kind of
act you know act properly respectful and
then I go off and I do my work I think
at this point stage of the game fairly
fairly well some it's a sinus projects
are much more complicated than the books
because the books actually do seem to be
by pure graphic design when I've done
signage projects a lot of times you know
the starting point is that every
architect thinks that the building
itself is the sign and doesn't require
any sign on it they also tend to
overestimate the logic of the plan and
will assume that no one needs any
direction to find anything in the
building including the bathrooms or
anything else and of course the
operators of the building if it's a
public building generally find out that
there there is a need sometimes legal or
by code for signs and sometimes just as
human beings have to go and they need to
know where the bathroom is and it's not
necessarily as obvious as you'd think so
there's so much as more tension and
doing that but a lot of times I'm I use
the same technique where I sort of will
rely on the architecture to Q me about
not just the plan or the program but
actually the physical elements of the
architecture of the hardware the way the
details are resolve will tip me off and
give us a lot of guidance in terms of
how the signage might look feel and
behave it's a good question yeah right
there
well the question is how have how does a
digital rebel the digital revolution
changed the presentation of this kind of
work I believe you mean not only how it
books change which I think I talked
about a little at the beginning but now
we have all these alternate ways of
accessing this kind of work which you
know as you know you know as you've
probably read has actually is profoundly
threatening the viability of publishing
overall not just publishing a fancy
monographs for the shelves of rizzoli
but uh you know making it really hard
for anyone to publish anything with so
much work available online so much
information available online Google and
Amazon kind of kind of going back and
forth with authors about how much work
could be available online in essentially
free you know so that's all of that has
to do with like rights and things like
that the more technical question which
is you know how is you know but in what
ways is work how is it different to view
work and these different platforms I
think with you another way to think
about it and I think of the in the early
days of website design the tendency
would be to conceive conceive a website
is some sort of you know on-screen
analogue to a printed brochure this we
get that term brochure aware right and
and I'm surprised actually there are a
lot I have some architects as clients
where I've done website or online
digital work for them and that that's
sort of 10 stood a little bit of that
tends to hold true very much so with
architects more than with other sorts of
clients I think part partly I think
because they tend to have this very sort
of organized way self-conscious and net
so penderson bad way become their very
conscious of the way the work is
presented and the sequence by which you
sort of see projects the way they're
organized the categories they fall in
the information you learn about the
projects is also is that in a way has
all been kind of well organized in in
amateur studios archive going back
millions of competitions and pitches and
answers to request for proposal you know
you've got projects sheets you have
capabilities stay
Vincent a lot of times websites almost
always are viewed as first and foremost
business development tools for
professional service firms whether there
are arginase lawyers or doctors or
anyone else and so in the big terror for
particularly an architect is that some
not particularly smart or maybe
inpatient facilities manager who has
been told to find some architects who
designed laboratory buildings for
college campuses you know will not will
come to your site and not discover that
one laboratory building you design for
that one college campus fast enough you
know and so though you'll go come
they'll see your site that looks like
you just design nothing but uh you know
summer houses and you know something
else and they sort of will strike you
off the list right so I think every
architects sort of just wants to make
sure that they're present and accounted
for when these phantom you know notional
never seen you know this is like you
know this fictional you know facilities
manager at a you know at the you know at
this at got rocks university is going to
be looking for you know that one big
Commission to award right so it's really
tough I found it might in fact I find
that much harder than designing the
books or even the signage just because
there's just like pret you know we don't
know who the audience is we don't know
what they're looking for but anyone can
do it you sort of can't get you can
interview them before they go on your
site to figure out what they're there
for and then that sort of leads to this
kind of exaggerated idea about what what
a website is supposed to do for people
you know um you know really i think all
it is supposed to do is pique someone's
interest enough that they actually send
an email or pick up the phone and call
you but I think there's this theory that
you know unless you can provide
exhaustive information that satisfies
every possible question you're going to
get bumped off the list and of course we
have no way of knowing which attitude is
true because there are so many people
out there and even user surveys don't
tend to surface the truth or they just
the results are some adamantly ambiguous
that is actually frustrating so that's
part of the answer the other part of the
answer has to do with purely technical
things like you know we've designed at
its height we designed some really great
websites or web site that I think a
really
cool that are based entirely in flash
all of those websites don't work on
iPads now because of the decision that
they made it Apple not to accommodate
flash as a software platform on ipad and
so on you know and there's they're
powerful enough with that device to
actually effectively change the game for
everyone else and so that ends up being
kind of a bit of a frustration and and
even when it's not quite as deliberately
frustrating is there just the change in
scale you get between a big monitor and
a iphone is actually a really critical
thing now and people do expect sort of
the same information set to render
appropriately on a big monitor and and
on a handheld device like a phone and
its sub did it just means we have to be
ever more nimble in terms of how we do
these things it also puts more pressure
on I think you guys as architects to
just get sort of philosophical but I
think it in a way it may end up putting
more pressure on coming up being our
ways to present your work so that no
matter what it is the image that that
represents a project is just so kind of
strong and simple and telegraphic that
it will look good in a big monograph
that big and we'll also kind of be
legible on an iPhone laughing I think
you know that's fairly reductive and
kind of chilling when you think about it
that way but I think that may be part of
the name of the game going forward Oh
what's yes sorry
right
yeah so the question is I'm sort of the
peculiar the the nature of exploring
something digitally which is not
sequential as a book is and kind of
plays this interesting game between two
dimensional representation and other
dimensions which could be time or could
be space you know what does that imply
and I think it's interesting because I
think that answer is changing all the
time and you know even now I'd say that
um we're like at this moment I think
what people are sort of getting very
attracted to our sites that tend to
function almost as databases in a way
where there's almost no design at all or
somehow the data itself is the malleable
thing and you know if you've done a
hundred projects in there each tag five
different ways and you can kind of like
sort them by date or sort them by a user
type or sort them by genre or sort them
by this and they reconfigure in all
these different ways that's sort of
that's something that you can only do
digitally that it's really cumbersome to
do with a book and once you sort of you
know they have tabs and indices and
stuff like that and that and that's like
one of the elements that I think is
attractive to people I've got two really
talented partners in New York that have
spent their whole lives doing this stuff
and they seem most interested in that
right now unless interested in actually
you know kind of treating the flat
screen as you know as space that implies
depth that sort of seems like something
that everyone is interested in a little
bit before not the greatest answer
whatever one would have a different one
you get a question there right
right
oh sure yeah yeah yeah the question was
on what are the challenges of dealing
with God you know yeah right right
well I think I'm if I mean the if if
you're dealing with a variety of medium
what do you have our everything that
could be in fact it wasn't just the
Sterling book is only I don't think
there's any finished work shown that I
think it's all drawings models sketches
stuff like that but like you know like
that Johnson book say if you picture
that lincoln center spread that shows
like a you know the glossy photograph is
on the right hand side and then
progressive sketches would look like
presentation sketches are working
drawings or elevations of the new york
state theater are shown on the left of
that page and i think basically there's
a couple challenges with that one is
that glossy photographs tend to sort of
be like and you know they like bonds you
know people the more real it looks the
more people are likely to attend to them
so a lot of times when you're staging
these things you have to do this sort of
you know there's a sort of like lifespan
that a project has right where it begins
as a sketch and then progresses along
and then the climax is meant to be this
glossy photograph I guess right so one
of the tactics you have is to kind of
exploit the basic narrative of that and
people's actual interests and sort of
seeing the genesis of things people
really are interested in sort of seeing
oh that was the original sketch to the
degree that I know at least several
famous architects who will contrive who
will go back and retrofit that original
sketch if it didn't already exist just
because it's so interesting to see the
the original sketch you know so you know
so I think a lot of times just that that
sense of you know here it was on the day
of its birth here it is you know when it
was fully grown is of interest to people
but what it requires I think is you
modulate that you have to kind of
balance that interest against peoples
natural tendency to sort of discount you
know the the stages in between in favor
of the big splashy ending right which if
it is indeed that color photograph of
the built thing in your case is likely
to be a equip do well photograph model
it could be a you know a rendering that
you've invested a lot of time and and
these these days
it's I mean rendering skills have gotten
so good that in some cases the
renderings are you know as you know
indistinguishable from the final build
thing it's so I think that's one way of
dealing with it another way I think in
that I usually tell people this is true
for the editors and the subjects of the
books I've dealt with and it's also true
for students it's some really judicious
and careful editing tends to be your
friend as well I think ones tendency is
you know if you've really done a lot of
work on something it's very tempting to
show all that work you know you did it I
want to show it right and it's um it's
it's really easy to lose sight of when
diminishing returns set in I mean
sometimes sort of you know if you've
really done you know you know a hundred
variations of something you know those
100 variations in a grid might be
fascinating in and of themselves right
but sort of like these my new changes
you know unless you know it's sometimes
people just get weary and essentially
just picking out the key ones that
actually show you know you know real
moments of development developmental
change in a project or is more important
that that will you you know in at least
a printed book you have limited real
estate so the more the fewer things you
show the more they can be big and then
particularly when it comes to drawings
and sketches and stuff like that the the
challenge is that they're you know they
just tend to be sometimes faint
sometimes hard you know much harder to
see and so much harder for people to
decipher than stuff that's more robust
so I think it's a editing it's
storytelling and editing are the two key
words there yeah
yeah oh yeah you want to know oh yeah
there's a history behind us eggs
absolutely the history of dust jack is I
promise this will be sure I promise is
that really rich people who are massing
libraries and were true presumably true
they might have been just the the dopey
predecessors duh today's McMansion
Owners but when when when a learned
person was putting together a library
one of the things they would do as a
matter of course was they would get all
the books rebound in their own
particular style so you would know is
from their library so covers then meant
nothing at all you would sort of buy a
book with an inexpensive paper cover
take it off and then we get it rebound
in a dust jacket more suited to your own
personal taste or not the Dutch jacket a
hardcover a cloth cover more suited to
your taste that's why particularly if
you're like in traveling in Europe you
go in a good book store you'll see those
you know piles of kind of like really
kind of literary you know literary books
from Italy let's say they'll have the
most boring covers in the world just a
color and a little bit of tight really
beautiful in a way but so different than
what your people which we call the
American Way which is like big loss or
names big vivid photographs right making
by the books right and so but when you
know that sort of evolved into well
people couldn't actually get their books
you know bound themselves so they'd have
a nice big common a nice cloth cover and
so the publisher is would control would
put the books in a nice cloth cover
which is the thing you see under the
dust jacket but then the marketing
people would say you know this book's
gotta sell so we have to do something a
bit more dramatic that'll sell it so
that's when the dust jacket came in so
actually dust jackets are meant to be
the wrapper around the actual book and
in fact i think as originally conceived
the idea would be that you would take it
by the book you you buy the book because
of the dust jacket let's say but then
then you throw the dust jacket off to
consume the book just as you throw the
boxes though you know you eat the cereal
you throw out the box it came in you
don't kind of treasure that and put that
on yourself and think yeah life cereal
you know 2004
excellent you know so I think you were
meant to throw those dust jackets out
then somewhere along the way in the 20th
century different graphic artists
started getting involved with dust
jacket design and it got progressively
more refined and so now I think that you
know people just assume the dust jackets
will be retained on the books now
however with the book as object as an
idea you know some books have dust
jackets still and in fact and if any
more there's sort of a signal now of
this is like a more normal book that you
would like buy and like read you know
you'd sit and you'd like read it on the
on at run the subway or you'd read it on
the beach you know or you read it like a
normal book and then books that sort of
have like more kooky covers which are
which could be what you call wrapped
cover which I think like that that um
the liebe skin book is a rap cover
there's no dust jacket on there that
silver thing actually was wrapped around
the board that that you'd otherwise wrap
a cloth a fake cloth cover around these
days and so a lot of those books some of
them were wrapped covers some of them
were dust jackets the difference usually
is it has a little bit to do with
conventionality versus progressiveness
or kind of book as object versus book as
meant to be read sort of things so it's
used as this fairly subtle signal and in
fact publishers are really interesting
to work with because so many books you
know a book is a consumer product when
it gets in a bookstore you really are
buying it like you're buying cereal you
know we'll see what happens now that
people can buy books online where
presumably the the tools of consumer
marketing like packaging like big
pictures like author names are all sort
of being leveled as you just sort of
sorting through something on your iPad
or buying things on Amazon or whatever
but um you know in a shelf and a Barnes
& Noble you know you're being marketed
to just as just as you would if you were
buying them you know razor blades or
cereal or or potato chips or anything
else the same techniques are being used
although book jacket designer is already
front or a refined breed of design or
who moving their own special circles and
join their own enjoy their own special
celebrity due to their contact they have
with famous authors sometimes which is
actually true and not exaggerated as
there's other times and sort of then
they get to keep all those books too
which is great for free as part because
they're paid so little often but I'm you
know so lucky thing on a store now you
can like all those the same design team
has designed all of Jonathan boers books
to have that kind of handwritten thing
you know the same really kind of and
even like you know Vladimir Nabokov who
was like really picky about the design
of his book jackets kind of eventually
kind of forced his publisher who I think
was harper and row I think to kind of
like design all the covers the same way
partly because he had seen a paperback
edition about let's see more than one
paperback edition of you guessed it
Elita that had all sorts unsavory
sensationalistic things on if they just
really seemed repugnant to him so he was
like really determined to have all those
books the same in fact the original
first editions of every one of those
books from Lolita to Pale Fire to speak
memory all look exactly the same they
had that Vladimir Nabokov brand and it's
just as relentless as you know IBM or
Apple or anything else would envy today
I would say so does that answer that
over answers your question are you sorry
you asked Thank nails but it's a
beautiful day thank you so much for
sitting in this on windowless auditorium
if I might go then you want to see these
things in a real-life have a couple
copies up here